ok tu
poi siamo
luci grazie velocemente benvenuto
benvenuti ad una nuova puntata dello
show con karim usa porca miseria quanto
mi siete mancati in voi non ne avete
idea avete detto di tutto in sto periodo
chiuso il canale questi sei mesi avete
anche creduto che io avessi veramente
aperto il padre one mannaggia a me lo
ricordo anche fatto un video per
spiegare questa cosa qui bravi bravi ma
come potrei mai andare via come potrei
raccontarvi le cose che succedono nel
mondo trash italiano dove potrei mai
raccontarvi che massimo boldi
recentemente ha twittato un suo vecchio
video dove lui è comunque alla sua
veneranda età si allena manco fosse
connor mcgregor caricando il video nel
canale di milly carlucci dove cazzo
posso raccontarvi queste cose qui se non
sul mio canale
ma bando alle ciance nuovo studio nuove
luci sempre torino anche se stiamo
girando a milano maturino non si fa ma
sigla
[Musica]
è quindi benvenuti nel nuovo ennesimo
lancio con karim moussa tanto cielo è
quanto mi piace cambiare postazione meno
male che adesso anche delle persone che
mi aiutano grazie
la parola chiave di oggi di questo
primissimo video se non si fosse capito
è evoluzione
allora partiamo da un punto cardine di
questo discorso
siamo tutti degli egocentrici figli di
[ __ ] soprattutto quelli che fanno
questo tipo di lavoro quelli che stanno
per anni anni dietro una telecamera
soltanto per il piacere di farlo e per
il grano da quello viene dopo
prima c'è il resto la creatività la
passione la dedizione e poi ci sono
canali che vanno avanti anche senza
queste qualità ma riescono a campare
comunque come continuando ad evolversi
appunto cercare di non far stagnare il
tutto come se fosse una triste
pozzanghere autunnale certo la paura di
perdere il pubblico c'è perché la gente
voi molto spesso pensate di sapere cosa
volete ma in realtà siete come il
bambino di due anni che rompe i [ __ ]
ai genitori a natale per avere un cazzo
di giocattolo poi ci gioca per due
minuti e lo molla ma non solo il
contenuto anche il format stesso può
portare diversi problemi durante il mio
studio delle ciò mentre stavo guardando
un episodio di epcc di cattelan a quanto
pare si chiama cattelan e non cattelan
mortacci tua che che hai dovuto dire sta
cosa non riuscirò mai a pronunciarlo
giusto e un episodio di cattelan
sono andato a leggere i commenti e
moltissime persone si lamentavano del
fatto che a man chiamo ci mettiamo pure
a copiare letterman allora
tralasciando il fatto che in lei cioè un
format ed è quello che al massimo viene
copiato letterman e comunque il nome più
sbagliato da associare ai pcc con tutti
il e ciò che assomigliano a quello di
cattelan ha scelto quello più sbagliato
per pura ignoranza e come dire che un
povero bimbo di 4 anni che disegna la
casetta stilizzata con il tetto
spiovente abbia copiato renzo piano
ma poi lei ciò in italia esistono da
anni anni soltanto che noi gli abbiamo
appunto
italianizzati che tempo che fa alla
struttura delle ciò il chiambretti night
alla struttura deve show sapete qual è
il programma che più si avvicina
all'immagine e alla struttura di un
leccio americano e proprio striscia la
notizia pensateci monologhi in piedi
battute rapine sketch e ospiti che io
pagherei oro per vedere jimmy fallon un
giorno urlare le veline
a volte basta semplicemente essere
ispirato dalla persona giusta per
esempio la mia non decapitiamo la magari
quindi chiara ferragni di cui tra
l'altro se non si dovesse vedere il il
cartonato anche un santino del
portafoglio non si sa mai
si sa mai bene assume un attimo la sua
vita soprattutto per quei detrattori
della domenica pomeriggio che già
staranno chiedendo ma dove chiara verrà
ivani cazzo è ma che cazzo affatto
chiara no in mutande sul divano dei
vostri genitori tre anni fuoricorso
dall'università che cercate il lavoro
sul cazzo di www.bolgherimelody.com che
decide di aprire un blog di moda dove
far vedere i suoi outfit al mondo intero
non è più un blog è un action platform
adesso tradizione iniziata e trattenuta
dal blog
questo blog diventa piano piano di
gigantesco nel 2010 la rivista americana
new york la nomina one of the biggest
breakout street style stars of the year
nel 2011 bug e la vota come blogger
dell'anno nel 2014 viene premiata per la
terza volta con il blog loving awards
nel 2015 fatturava circa 10 milioni
di euro 10 10 milioni sapete cosa
significa a fatturare nel 2015 di 10
milioni di euro
vuol dire che nella sua famiglia fedez e
quello povero e fin qui va bene ma non è
questa la storia dichiara che volevo
raccontarvi o almeno non di questa
chiara probabilmente molti di pioggia la
conosceranno questa storiella qui però è
giusto ogni tanto rinfrescare la memoria
lei è sempre chiara ma nel 2009 quando
si faceva chiamare diavoletta 87 questo
è proprio sugli argomenti che nutrono il
mio animo finalmente diavoletto 87 era
il nick che chiara usava nel suo
primissimo diario online ed era una
cazzo di truzza pop killer in a shock
angel devil techno folle di quelle
persone che festeggiano ogni mese di
fidanzamento scrivendo sui muri sui
marciapiedi o sugli specchi
il loro amore e lo so lo so che questa
non è una notizia proprio di nuovo ma io
sono rimasto positivamente allibito chi
ha fatto le superiori come me nei primi
anni del 2000 sicuramente si ricorderà
il genere quelle che a torino beccavi
alle serate di genti luca pussycat ad
urlare che bel periodo che e ci sono
anche dei piccoli rimasugli del suo
diario
oggi ho preso la patente e se ntr felice
baci a tutti che usate hicks il post
assolutamente banale ma sn davvero presa
bene
in quel periodo era fidanzata con il
signor albertino dj e no non quella
albertino dj provate a immaginare questo
ragazzo che oggi riguarda le foto e
pensa che sarebbe potuto essere lui li
su quell'altare io però vorrei io sono
curioso di sapere dov'è finito questo
signore albertino dj se stai guardando
questo video e sai più o meno tutte
quelle cose lì del periodo diavoletto 87
primi contatti per cortesia adesso ciò
la scrivania grande posso anche invitare
degli ospiti e quando tu sedicenne
alternativo che era l'esatto opposto di
queste persone ti sentivi quasi
superiore con la tua maglietta dei korn
e pensando ma da grande
e questa dove cazzo ma sono sicuro che
finirà in una roulotte a dare da
mangiare ai cani randagi per evitare che
la vicina non ti saresti mai mai
immaginato che dieci anni dopo sarebbe
cambiato tutto che si sarebbe evoluto
tutto secondo me è la storia di chiara
deve essere prese in considerazione da
tutti perché se ce l'ha fatta
questa chiara ce la possiamo fare tutti
basta avere il coraggio di buttarsi ed
essere mediamente attraenti avere anche
un fidanzato fotografo che ti aiuta a
fare le foto per il blog e che aiuta ad
aprire il blog è avere una mamma che gli
sproni a fare quel lavoro lì ed aprire
un blog nel 2008 a parte tutte queste
cose qua tutti possiamo farcela come
dice la mia amica nadia toffa basta
crederci
[Musica]
caro diario dei mails foglio che lo show
abbia successo e finalmente poter
diventare famoso come chiara e come voi
che fate i diari per la scuola anche fa
vj ha il suo diario invece tutti gli
altri famosi ma molto meno li mettono
ammassati nella comics come i neri che
si sedevano in fondo al pullman
c'è ancora il diario di tua madre
leggenda
ok pensa nel diario della comics
c'è addirittura al fauno man che strano
e come se nel diario di spiderman e ad
un certo punto ci fosse un enorme cazzo
ma se non potete farmi fare il diario mi
accontento di poco
vorrei poter diventare muscolosissimo e
i fari video con fedez così posso
entrare nella sua squadra di youtubers
famosi famosi e poi fare come lui
conquistare il cuore di una signorina
ricca dello show business non è stato
neanche difficile a quanto pare lui ha
nominato chiara in una canzone
lei si è divertita e ha canticchiato
quella canzone in auto lui le ha mandato
uno snap chat dove le diceva chiara
limon chiamo lei ha risposto abbiamo
iniziato a scriverci mi ha invitato a
cena e io ho pensato bello mi piace così
diretto i ragazzi oggi sono troppo
indecisi
allora lo faccio anche io ciao matilda
vorrei usare una tecnica di rimorchio
con te è quella che ha usato fedez con
chiara ferragni
e ha funzionato quindi matilda limon
chiamo spero che riusciate ad esaudire i
miei sogni match anche perché questo è
solo l'inizio
[Musica]